very
airy and it's kind of melts in your
mouth hi guys it's riya today i'm going
to show you three very different kind of
cheesecake some of them are a little bit
challenging don't worry there are some
hacks that help you make perfect
cheesecake first japanese souffle
cheesecake first i want to prep cake pan
i'm using six inch spring foam pan i'm
going to grease my pan so the parchment
sticks better i'm gonna use knife to
cut
springform pan comes with two piece and
we are going to use water bus cooking
method if you put in a water there is a
gap and water comes into the pan so i'm
going to use aluminium foil i think
spring foam pan is better for this cake
so you can easily remove it from the pan
now
the most difficult part is done let's
get to the fun part first i'm adding
cream cheese butter and heavy cream we
are going to use double boiler so you
are going to mix until evenly smooth i'm
going to set this aside and i'm going to
separate egg whites and egg yolk
and i'm going to add egg yolk in here
nice color
and one tablespoon of lemon juice
usually half lemon makes one tablespoon
lemon juice now i am going to
sift
cornstarch
i enjoy baking a lot of course my
favorite part is like eating
this is already pretty smooth but i want
to make it extra smooth and make sure
there's no cream cheese chunks i'm going
to put this in the refrigerator to chill
so it will incorporate better with my
meringue now i have egg whites
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm going to add sugar gradually it's
kind of like in between soft peak and
hard pick so this is the mixture i made
earlier then i'm going to take
about one
fourth
of the meringue
incorporated well the first mix is done
and i'm going to add all the rest of the
meringue
and try not to
over mix here but make sure there is no
meringue white stream it's visible
now i'm going to add this
in a mold yeah nice ribbon and i'm gonna
just tap
so there is no
big bubble i use paper towel underneath
it
so it doesn't give a direct heat or hot
water about halfway of the spring foam
pan oven temperature is a very important
factor for this cheesecake when i tested
it cracked so many times so first we are
going to bake this lower heat 250 for 16
minutes increase the heat for 325 and
bake for 10 minutes let's go to the oven
this cake is baked you want to eat right
away right but this cake is taste better
if you chill in a refrigerator at least
two hours or preferably overnight i'm
gonna
a mold
reveal
i'm brushing apricot jam just make the
top shiny and here we have it japanese
cheesecake look how pretty they are
can't wait to have a bite
it's really light but kind of still have
like nice cheesecake flavor just like
taste of my childhood and i think this
is very different and very good contrast
from the cheesecake i'm making next
let's do it we are on to the american
cheesecake and i think the best part
it's the bottom everyone is nodding here
all right so let's get started first we
have 12 gram crackers made into crumbs
one stick butter
combine well
right i'm using a nine inch
spring foam pan grease
i'm going to add clumps
dry cup measurement it's the perfect
things to use
kind of press
i think that's good so we are going to
bake this at 350 degrees for 20 minutes
and let it cool for room temperature
i'll be right back
oh very good now i'm going to make
fillings first i'm going to crack eggs
and i'm going to use forex
i have 24 on seed cream cheese add sugar
and cream together i'm going to add egg
one by one
i'm going to add vanilla extract
butter is ready and crust is ready i'm
going to use foil technique that i
showed you for japanese cheesecake so
the water doesn't get in we are going to
use water bath technique instead of just
baking in the oven so it's foolproof so
it won't crack now i'm going to add a
piece of paper towel
put the pan in and add the butter
and shake it and i'm going to add hot
water and we are going to bake this at
350 for one hour or the center is
slightly still jiggly but outside is
kind of set it's
go
so i baked this cheesecake and let it
chill for 12 hours to overnight and i'm
going to just decorate i like decorating
i think it's kind of nice gives a nice
pop i like to add mint and filling the
gap here we have it
american cheesecake
it's very rich and it's very dense nice
contrast with the crust underneath i
think adding fresh fruits it gives a
nice contrast with rich cream cheese to
fresh ribs this cheesecake is great but
next one is very exciting the last
cheesecake we are making is basque
cheesecake this is known as a burnt
cheesecake so you are going to bake it
like super high heat and this one is
super easy to make
i have two pounds of cream cheese and
i'm adding sugar
okay i think this is nice and creamy and
all the sugar is dissolved and
incorporated i'm going to add eggs
one by one so first egg
scrape the side i'm going to add two
cups of heavy cream and make sure it's
room temperature and i'm going to add a
slurry and i'm going to add two teaspoon
of vanilla
and one teaspoon of salt
i'm going to sift
flour and if you have a stand mixer you
can totally use the stand mixer
all right butter is done and i'm going
to prepare my mold right so bask
cheesecake hack basket cheesecake you
want to crumble the parchment paper but
it's difficult to line if you crumble it
kind of have a gap and it doesn't line
well but if you soak in the water
it's easier to line first you have kind
of rumble
soak in the water
paper kind of become a little bit
flexible
a little bit moisture it's fine it
doesn't affect anything for the cake i'm
gonna just pour
so i'm going to bake this at 400 degrees
for 50 to 60 minutes the top is dark
brown and the center part is kind of
jiggly but it will set as a cold so
don't worry about it let's bake this
all right we baked it and let it cool to
room temperature and look at this
it is pretty dark brown this is what you
want
the color is very unique and also the
texture is the most beautiful thing
about this basque cheesecake if you're a
beginner baker i think this is the best
cheesecake to try for the first time
because you just mix it and bake in a
high temperature you don't need to worry
about cracking because you want to burn
you will gain the confidence i like how
rustic this look let some mold
kind of smell like a little bit
caramelized smell
hmm
so different unreal
so it kind of like s'more you want to
burn the marshmallow right i made three
different cheesecake today japanese
souffle cheesecake american cheesecake
and basque cheesecake i hope you guys
enjoy watching this video if you make
any of those cheesecake tag me on
instagram and see you next time thank
you for watching
oh yes
you